FEMALE SPEAKER:
Welcome, everybody.
Please join us in welcoming
Haben Girma today to Google.
She is a Harvard Law graduate,
the first deaf-blind graduate
from Harvard Law School.
And she is a pioneer
in everything
that has to do with
technology for accessibility.
So she has been helping
a very, very in depth
with developing technology
that is useful for people
with disabilities.
She is also a Disability
Rights Advocates member,
and encourages the development
of any sorts of accessible
technology.
She's here today to
talk to us about how
technology has enabled her
to be where she is today.
And she also encourages
all of us, being at Google,
to help with further development
of these types of technologies.
And with me, I have
[? Umrit ?] who
has gotten to know Haben
at Harvard Law School.
So he'll tell you
a little bit more
of a personal story about her.
UMRIT: Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
I'm sure as the
project introduction
kind of foretold, and as you've
probably seen in Haben's bio,
and everything else
that's written about her
in many different places.
She's an incredible,
inspiring, influential person.
But a project
and-- Not but, and.
[INAUDIBLE] asked me
just to share just
a quick, personal, anecdote.
And with the one thing
I wanted to say--
and the truth is you'll
see this very soon,
is that the Haben is one
of the most optimistic,
encouraging, and curious
people that I've ever met.
And I think that's one of
things that really shines out
about her.
Some of you will I think
you hear this in her voice.
But you'll really sense it in
the words that she's saying.
So as [INAUDIBLE]
had mentioned, Haben
ans I went to law
school together,
actually quite a number of years
ago now, which seems strange.
And we met in our
first year law school.
And in that community, in the
law school community, actually
also beyond it, Haben
and in some ways
actually extended my boundaries
beyond the law school bubble
pretty quickly.
She, again, was known
for being someone
who's just absolutely
optimistic, absolutely positive
and engaging in that way.
And I feel very lucky
that she lives here.
Although, sometimes the East Bay
feels really, really far away.
But I think one
thing I've noticed
even here is that Haben's
friends are all really
fascinating, amazing people.
And it's no surprise, in a way.
Just the one last thing
I wanted to mention
was that I had taken--
the one that I recalled
when [INAUDIBLE] had asked
if I could just to share
a few words, is that I had
taken Haben to the opera,
I guess last year, now.
And by the way, slight plug, all
of you should go to the opera.
Because Google gives--
the San Jose Opera,
Google gives, like, $30
tickets for front row seats,
which is an amazing perk.
So I used that Perk
and took Haben with me.
And one thing that was very
clear was at the perspective
that she's able to, and
willing to, and curious enough
to share throughout
the experience,
was just in kind of
fulfills, and even takes
further my own experience.
She did, during
the intermission,
though, get really excited.
Because we're talking about
something that the opera
house could have done better.
And she said, hey, [? Umrit ?],
we should sue the opera house.
And I remember thinking in
that moment, a note to self,
that I should never
bring Haben to Google.
[LAUGHTER]
And can then go in a
project that did just that.
But all joking aside, I'm
actually very encouraged,
and happy that Haben is
fighting the good fight,
fighting these fights.
And sometimes that might mean,
probably already has meant,
but it almost
certainly will mean,
suing Google in some capacity.
Or at least challenging
Google to do things better.
And I am glad that
someone who has, again,
that optimism, that curiosity,
and that encouragement
is the one that's
the challenging.
So, that's it.
And I should
introduce [? Gopi ?].
Are you going to take over now?
No.
[? Gopi ?] is going to
take over at some point.
You all know him.
He's amazing.
All right.
Without anything else, Haben.
[APPLAUSE]
HABEN GIRMA: Good afternoon.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
HABEN GIRMA: My
name is Haben Girma.
I am so grateful to be here.
Thank you, [? Umrit ?], for
the wonderful introduction,
and reminding me
of the opera trip.
[LAUGHTER]
HABEN GIRMA: So, I work at
Disability Rights Advocates.
It's a nonprofit legal
center based in Berkeley.
And we help increase access
for people with disabilities.
One of the reasons I'm
really excited to be here
is that Google has an
extraordinary mission
to organize the
information of the world,
and make it
accessible, and useful.
In honor of the 25th
anniversary of the Americans
with Disabilities
Act, I want to talk
about what we can do
to make information
more accessible for
people with disabilities.
So first, I want to talk
about communication.
I'm deaf-blind.
So if you have a question,
and raise your hand,
it's going to be up
there for a long time.
[LAUGHTER]
And if you shout it out, I'm
not going to be able to hear it.
So for communication, I use a
keyboard in Braille display.
I'll hold up the
Braille display.
On the bottom are
mechanical pins
that pop up to form
Braille letters.
And when someone
types on the keyboard,
it shows up in digital Braille.
Technology helps
a lot of people.
And as programmers and
technology developers,
you really change the lives
of people with disabilities.
The technology I use
was developed by people.
And they've changed my
life, and they continue
to change the lives of others.
And all of you
here have the power
to help people, and really
change the lives of people.
One in four Americans
have a disability
at some point in their life.
That's a huge segment
of the population.
It includes the elderly.
It includes people who
are born with disabilities
and people who have experiences,
or temporary disabilities.
So thinking about
designing technologies
that will reach
these communities,
and empower them to gain
access to information,
it's really, really meaningful.
There are a variety of assistive
technologies people use.
Screen readers, are one example.
Screen readers are
applications that
convert graphical information
into synthesize speech,
or digital Braille, like the
Braille display I was holding.
These serve as bridges that
allow blind individuals
to access information
on screens.
So when developers put in
hooks for their products,
and services to connect
with screen readers,
blind individuals are
able to gain access
to online services,
and other products.
Another feature is
closed captioning.
Closed captioning are
subtitles on the bottom
of videos that allow deaf
individuals to access
the audio content on videos.
Closed captioning is a feature
that helps the deaf and hard
of hearing community.
But it also helps to
other communities.
Often places will have videos
with the audio turned off,
and closed captions turned on.
So little things like that
end up helping everyone.
Keyboard shortcuts
are helpful for people
with mobility disabilities
that affect the use of hands.
But they're also helpful for
people who just plain don't
like using mice.
Sometimes it's faster to
use keyboard shortcuts.
So these are all features
that people have developed,
that engineers, programmers,
technology developers
have imagined creating, and
then went through and created,
and have changed how people
engage with information,
and engage with each other.
Technology has revolutionized
all aspects of our lives
from entertainment, to
reading, to shopping.
Online shopping has really
impacted the lives of people
with disabilities in the
area of physical access.
A lot of stores,
physical stores,
have physical
barriers, like stairs,
that make it hard for someone in
a wheelchair to get in and out,
if there are no
accessible entrances.
And online shopping gives
people the opportunity
to bypass those
physical obstacles.
Chat programs, blogging programs
have allowed many communities
to start engaging, and having
conversations, that might not
have otherwise occurred.
Individuals on the
autism spectrum,
individuals who are
deaf or hard of hearing,
are now having conversations,
and connecting, and engaging.
And programmers, and
technology developers
who have built these programs,
like Google Hangouts,
have allowed individuals
in those communities
to connect, and
share their voices.
So as developers of technology,
you have a very powerful tool.
And in some ways, it's
opened many doors.
The vast majority of websites,
and apps, are not accessible.
But you can change that.
It's an incredible gift and
tool that you have to change.
The process is about
designing products
from the start with hooks
for assistive technology,
like screen readers, allowing
for captioning, allowing
for keyboard shortcuts.
And when you design it from
the start with those features
in mind, you're able
to ensure that it's
going to be accessible.
Helping people with disabilities
participate in the process
by allowing for testing at
every stage of development,
those are ways to
ensure that products
can help all Americans.
The challenge is continually
coming up with ways
to ensure that
people can connect.
Sometimes it's
really challenging,
and you get stuck
in a comfort zone
where you're doing
something just one way.
And it becomes difficult to
imagine new, exciting ways
for sharing information.
But this is Google.
This is Google, with an
extraordinary mission
to organize the
information of the world,
and make it
accessible, and useful.
I'm not a technology developer.
I'm not a programmer.
So I don't know all
the technical details
of the challenges involved.
But I do know how hard it
is to continue imagining
new ways of doing things.
One way I connect with
people is through dance.
I've been dancing
for about 10 years.
And because I can't
hear the music,
and I can't see what my
dance friends are doing,
I had to come up
with alternative ways
of experiencing rhythm,
and knowing the dance
moves by using my hands.
In over 10 years,
I've come up with lots
of different techniques
for accessing
the rhythm, and the movements.
But I realized that there was
still one very important thing
that I just wasn't picking up.
About two weeks ago I was
dancing, and during the dance,
the guy I was dancing with
raised his hand to his face
and signed, smiling.
I felt so surprised.
He's telling me he's smile?
What a beautiful thing to
communicate smiling while
dancing.
It never occurred to me.
Smiles are visually available
information to most people.
And now I know that
when I'm dancing,
I can tell people-- By the
way, if you're smiling,
and you want to tell me,
you could sign smiling.
So sometimes it's challenging to
think of new ways to do things.
But it's a fun challenge,
and very rewarding.
And when you come up with new
ways of presenting information,
you reach more
people, and it moves
Google closer to its
goal, its mission,
of gathering the
information, and making
it accessible, and useful.
Features that help the
disability community
often end up helping
the greater community.
Closed captioning
helps people who
are deaf or hard of hearing.
The text associated
with those videos
serves as a way to
allow for greater,
more powerful keyword
searches, allowing people
to access exactly the video,
and information, they want.
So a feature like closed
captioning, and other assistive
technologies, end up helping
the greater community.
I'm really, really
excited to see how we all
move towards the mission
of making information
more accessible for everyone.
About 25 years ago, Congress
passed the Americans
with Disabilities Act.
And it represents our country's
belief that everyone's equal,
and everyone deserves
opportunities in America.
There are challenges
associated with technology,
but also, almost
unlimited potential.
The World Wide Web Consortium
has created resources
to help with technical
specifics on how
to make services accessible.
The Web Content
Accessibility Guidelines 2.0
is an excellent resource.
For mobile applications,
the BBC mobile
accessibility guidelines.
But also here at Google,
there are many resources,
and many people, who have this
information of what it takes
to make services, and
products accessible to people
with disabilities.
The disability community wants
to access all the information
online, wants too access all
the websites and services.
We want to be part
of the digital world.
We want to be able to use the
apps in the Google Play Store.
And later we want
to drive your cars.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm excited to see
where Google goes,
and where we all
go, towards the goal
of making information
accessible for everyone.
And now I'll take questions.
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Just raise your
hand if you have a question.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So my
question to Haben
is, you just came back
from the White House.
I saw Obama in the photograph,
as well as Joe Biden.
What was the experience like?
What did you discuss?
HABEN GIRMA: It
was unbelievable.
I went to the White
House in celebration
of the 25th anniversary
of the Americans
with Disabilities Act.
And there were disability
rights advocates
from all over the country
gathered to celebrate.
And I gave introductory
remarks before Obama's speech.
And I met President
Barack Obama,
and spoke at them briefly.
And he used the
technology we have here.
He typed on the
keyboard, and I read
what he was typing on
the Braille display.
And I voiced my responses.
And we talked about
typing, and communication.
And then I thanked
him for his work
in helping to increase access
for people with disabilities.
What are some of
the big commitments
the US administration has made
for people with disabilities?
One major thing, the White
House was celebrating on Monday,
is increased hiring
people with disabilities.
They're more and more
people with disabilities
in all areas of government from
working at the White House,
to working in different
federal agencies.
In 2010 President Obama and
the Department of Justice
announced rule
making that they plan
to release that would set
regulations for website access.
And those are just
two of the things.
But there's a lot
that the US has
been doing to increase access
for people with disabilities,
both in the physical world, and
in the online, digital world.
AUDIENCE: Eunice
is asking, do you
know how the situation
is in other countries?
How do, for example, non-Latin
people use Braille display?
HABEN GIRMA: So do I
know about the situation
in other countries, and
how they use, for example,
Braille displays?
There are many different
types of Braille displays,
and they have the
ability to present
Braille in other languages.
So Braille is supported in many
different languages, including
Spanish, German, and French.
And when I've
traveled in Europe,
I've encountered Braille
in other languages.
Like in Spain, a lot
of things at stores,
like shampoo bottles, will
have Braille labels in Spanish.
[LAUGHTER]
So there are different
things in other countries.
And every country approaches
access slightly differently.
In China, for example,
on the sidewalks
they have raised to
paths, tactile paths
in the middle of the sidewalk,
so that a blind person
can feel with
their feet the path
in the middle of the sidewalk.
And I believe both China,
and Japan, and Hong Kong,
have made an effort to have
audio signals at intersections.
I've also heard Hong Kong
has Braille labels at street
corners.
So when you get to
a street corner,
you can read what
intersection that is.
Here in the United
States, we have
a little bit of that in a
few places, but not as much.
I've also been to Ethiopia.
And I know that the
University of Addis Ababa
has a program that supports
students with disabilities.
And they're working on
getting more technology.
But there's a huge need
for funding for technology
like Braille displays, Braille
printers, Braille books.
So every country has their
own challenges, but also
their own unique solutions.
AUDIENCE: The
question is, thanks
so much for telling
us your story.
I was wondering if
there are any Google
products that you like using.
Also, I was wondering if you
use an iPhone, or Android?
[LAUGHTER]
HABEN GIRMA: Great question, RJ.
So, Google has so many
products and services.
It's unbelievable.
And I mentioned chat computer
conversation applications.
And I've been using
Google Chat, which
I believe is now
called Google Hangouts,
for many, many, many years.
And that has been an amazing way
to connect with people, since I
can't really hear on the phone.
A lot of people like
using it, even people
without disabilities.
But for me, it's
been an amazing way,
and I know for other people
with disabilities, people
with hearing loss, people
on the autism spectrum,
it's facilitated so
many connections.
And it has allowed
a lot of communities
to grow, and connect.
And then for your last question,
I happen to use an iPhone.
AUDIENCE: [? Umrit ?]
is typing, hey Haben,
I have a quick follow up.
Which Google products
do you not like?
Which ones could, or
should, be improved?
HABEN GIRMA: That's an
interesting question,
and a really good one.
Thanks for encouraging me
to be honest about that.
[LAUGHTER]
So one product that is
actually really, really cool,
and I would love
to see improved,
is audio captioning
for YouTube videos.
The idea is fantastic of
having computers automatically
caption videos.
That creates so
many opportunities,
so many potentials,
for the deaf community,
but also for the
hearing community,
to allow for greater
interactivity, greater searches
for video, and information.
So improving audio captioning
for YouTube videos.
It would be great if people
could prioritize that.
AUDIENCE: The question
is, I was wondering
if you could tell us a little
more about your experience
transitioning from
Harvard after being
in school for many, many years.
HABEN GIRMA: I graduated from
Harvard Law School in 2013,
and then immediately started as
a Skadden fellowship attorney
at Disability Rights Advocates.
And the transition
was actually not hard,
because during law school, I
participated in internships.
And those internships
gave me an idea
of what to expect
in the work world.
And because Disability
Rights Advocates
is all about supporting
people with disabilities,
it was-- it is a very
supportive environment
in getting the accommodations
I need for work.
So we worked out having a
communication assistant who
would transcribe phone
calls, transcribes meetings,
and if there were presentations,
or if I go to court,
and there's hearings,
to get someone
to type that information, so I
can have captions in Braille.
So the transition was
helped by the fact
that I had internship
opportunities
while I was in law school.
I'm also from San
Francisco Bay area.
I grew up in Oakland.
And my family's still here,
and I had friends here.
So moving back
here after school,
I already had a support network.
So that helped a whole lot.
AUDIENCE: The first question
out of two questions she has is,
what do you have
to say to people
who do not have disabilities,
and who make excuses
for not following their dreams?
And her next question
is, do you also Amharic?
I watched your videos, and
I learned that your parents
are from Ethiopia, and Eritrea.
HABEN GIRMA: My family is
from Eritrea, and Ethiopia.
My mom grew up in Eritrea, and
my dad grew up in Ethiopia.
And they both speak Amharic,
Tigrinya, and English.
So growing up, they
taught me English
so I could succeed in
education, and work.
They taught me Tigrinya so
that we could talk in public,
and no one would understand us.
[LAUGHTER]
But they saved Amharic
for themselves,
so they could have secrets,
and I wouldn't understand
what they were saying.
So I don't know Amharic, just
a word or two here and there.
And I think being Eritrean
has helped a lot in my need
to pursue dreams.
Eritreans worked hard
fighting for 30 years
to gain independence
from Ethiopia.
And I grew up hearing
those stories.
It doesn't directly have
to do with disabilities,
but it taught me that
perseverance is important.
And it's important to keep
trying, even for 30 years.
So growing up, I didn't
exactly know all the answers
to how to do things, as
someone who's deaf-blind.
Often, I was the first
one trying something.
Harvard University had Helen
Keller almost 100 years ago.
And back then the technology
we have doesn't exist.
She's an incredible role model
for pursuing your dreams,
and doing things even if you
don't have the technology.
So I knew that one way or
another, I could do it.
She did it without computers,
without digital Braille.
So I could absolutely do it.
I didn't know exactly how.
She hadn't gone to law school.
And she hadn't utilized
the technologies
that are available.
But I knew I had to try
and make it work somehow.
And your first
question, Susanna,
what do I tell people who don't
have disabilities, and yet,
have excuses for
not doing something?
You live only once.
Your dreams are your dreams.
And if they mean something
to you, keep trying.
Keep trying to make them happen.
If it takes 30
years, it's better
you tried and win after 30
years, then not trying at all.
If you don't know how you're
going to do something,
because you're unique,
and your experiences are
different from others,
take a deep breath,
and start brainstorming.
Use the skills that you do have.
Network with other people, and
get advice from other people.
Everyone has dreams.
And it's up to us
to make them happen.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER: [? Umrit ?]
is letting Haben
know that her jokes were a hit.
The whole room was laughing.
And [? Gopi ?] was
signing with smiles.
HABEN GIRMA: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Daniel is typing,
I'm deaf, functionally
hearing impaired.
I'm very impressed
with your enunciation.
My question is, how does
the situation in the US
compare to other G10
countries in terms
of disability legislation,
and also good faith
adherence to the law?
HABEN GIRMA: That's something
that a lot of people
have been researching.
Every community has different
attitudes towards disabilities.
Some communities celebrate
difference a lot more.
In China, where the emphasis
is on being the same,
it's a lot harder
to be different.
And it's a lot harder
to get accommodations,
such as interpreters,
captioning, digital Braille.
But in other cultures, the
individual's uniqueness
is more celebrated.
So you asked specifically
about laws and legislation.
I haven't studied the disability
laws of other countries.
So I can't offer an
answer to that right now,
but I'd be happy
to look that up.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Kenneth's saying,
I'm also impressed
with your speech.
It's usually very
hard for a deaf person
to learn to speak so well
without audio feedback.
Can you describe your
own educational process?
HABEN GIRMA: I will
talk about my education.
But I also want to
talk about my speech,
since people seem
to be interested.
[LAUGHTER]
So, I identify as deaf-blind.
And the deaf-blind community
is very, very diverse.
And that includes everyone
with no vision, and no hearing,
to a little vision,
and a little hearing.
And I have a little
bit of hearing
and a little bit of vision.
And my low frequency
is terrible.
I have a really hard time
hearing low frequency sounds.
Or I just don't
hear them at all.
High frequency I
can kind of hear.
And my voice is high frequency.
And I think I may have
somewhat trained myself
to speak at a higher
voice to make it easier
for me to hear myself.
So that's part of the reason
that I speak the way I speak.
My education, I grew
up in the Bay Area,
and I attended
mainstream schools.
And the school
had a program that
made sure students who were
blind or students who were deaf
were taught the skills
they needed to know.
So I would take my mainstream
courses with other students,
and then take an hour
each day to learn Braille,
learn to use
assistive technology,
learn to use a cane,
learn to do life skills,
like cooking non-visually.
It's all about finding
alternative techniques
that allow you to succeed,
and pursue your dreams.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Bethany's
saying, your story about dance
was wonderful.
What other types of visual,
or oral information,
would you like to know about
from the physical world?
HABEN GIRMA: So usually people
will type visual information
from the physical world.
So when someone's typing, they
might use an exclamation mark,
or type colon,
right parentheses,
or just type S-M-I-L-E.
Friends will also describe
what someone is wearing,
or interesting
artwork on the wall.
Lots of descriptions.
There's also something
called Pro-Tactile,
which transfers some of
that information physically.
So someone could draw smile
on my arm, or signal laughter.
There's sign language.
And I could put my
hand on someone's hand
and feel what they're signing.
So there's that whole
world of communicating
visual information in
an alternative format.
And I knew that.
But until two weeks ago,
it never occurred to me
to do that while dancing.
So for 10 years, people have
been smiling at me on the dance
floor, and I didn't know.
[LAUGHTER]
But I learned.
And I'm really grateful to have
that additional information.
And I'm excited to use it
the next time I go dancing.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Boston says, it's
really awesome to see Haben
speak for the first time,
in person.
He has two questions.
The first one is, are there any
suites of apps on your iPhone
that are tailored for
a blind-deaf person?
And the second is, do you
follow any medical innovations
that help blind-deaf persons?
HABEN GIRMA: I feel like I'm
so busy living, and working,
and dancing, and
talking with friends,
that I don't have time left
over to follow medical research.
But I ask friends
and family to let
me know if they've heard
of something exciting,
or something new.
Because I'm open to
new possibilities.
And I love new research,
and new developments,
and learning new things.
I have an app on my
phone called BlindSquare.
And BlindSquare
is a travel tool.
And it'll tell you how
to get from point A
to point B. What's the
nearby intersection?
What's your approximate address?
It's designed to be 100%
compatible with a screen reader
called VoiceOver on the iPhone.
I would love to have Google Maps
be 100% accessible because that
has so many features,
and so many potentials.
But it's not at that level yet.
So Boston, if you know people
working on Google Maps,
could you share
this message for me?
It's actually not that
difficult to make these services
accessible with screen readers.
there a guides here at Google.
So, Google has
accessibility guidelines.
And there's information
on how to make
most services accessible.
I think people maybe
just don't know, and need
to be reminded, that people
are out there excited to use
these services, and are
waiting to make them happen.
Thanks to [? Gopi ?]
for making this happen,
and, [INAUDIBLE] and
[? Umrit, ?] and Grace.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Christy was
thanking Haben for coming
and talking to us today.
Christy's asking, I have a
family friend who's disabled,
and studying to be involved
in disability advocacy.
Do you have any advice
I can pass along to her?
HABEN GIRMA: It's
really, really helpful
to connect with the
disability community.
So when I was thinking
about going into law school,
I reached out to the blind,
and the deaf community.
And I talked to a
bunch of deaf lawyers.
How did you make it
through law school?
What advice do you have for me?
And I reached out to
the National Federation
of the Blind and asked,
all their blind lawyers,
what advice do you have for
me for going to law school?
What are the
alternative techniques
you use for getting your books?
For doing online research?
So every disability
experience is very unique.
So my advice would be connect
with that specific disability
community, and get advice from
people who have tried that,
or have done something--
who have done
something in a related area.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sarah's
saying, you've inspired us all.
You mentioned that Helen Keller
went to Harvard 100 years ago.
Following your
tremendous success,
are you seeing more people
that are deaf-blind modeling
your success?
Going to Harvard,
and law school?
HABEN GIRMA: I need to correct
something I said earlier.
So at the time of Helen
Keller, Harvard, strangely,
with only men.
And the equivalent for
women was Radcliffe College.
Later Harvard opened
its doors to women,
and Radcliffe College became
part of Harvard University.
So technically, at the time, it
was called Radcliffe College.
But it's now part of
Harvard University.
And more, and more
people with disabilities
are going to law school,
and are getting educations.
I don't know of any other
deaf-blind students at Harvard.
But I do know,
currently, there are
other blind students, and other
deaf students at Harvard Law
School.
And I know of
deaf-blind students
who are going to other law
schools throughout the country.
A lot of this is
because the technology,
and because people like
you are taking the time
to make sure that services
are accessible to people
with disabilities.
I can't imagine trying to have
gone to law school at a time
without all the services
we now have available.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]